well we got Rhonda santis in his uh  victory speech we have embraced Freedom  we have  our taxpayers and we reject woke  ideology  I really like the United States man we  fight the woken  at the woke in the schools we fight the  woke and the corporations we will never  ever surrender to the woke mob Florida  is where woke goes to die oh there it is  there it is Florida is where the wolf  goes to die it's looking like Georgia  may go to a runoff election this means  you're you're going to need Mass  Republican turnout again  and that's gonna that's that's gonna be  tough we'll see I mean Democrats aren't  turning out the numbers that the  Democrats were hoping for or I should  say what could they really hope for what